more mass effect Andromeda details have
arrived including clues about what we
can expect from the game's multiplayer
mode and framerate producer Fernando
Miller confirmed on Twitter that
Andromeda won't feature cross-play
between PC and Xbox for the game's
multiplayer mode he added that the
multiplayer will be peer to peer as was
the case with mass effect 3 jul Jacques
is also reporting that Bioware has
confirmed Andromeda's pc version will
have an unkempt frame rate this
shouldn't come as a big surprise as
Bioware general manager Ehren Flynn
suggested that the framerate wouldn't be
capped on PC earlier this month on
NeoGAF elsewhere in the jewel Jacques
article it was reported that you'll be
able to choose what kind of training
Ryder had in the Milky Way and their
backstory will depend on your selection
more details about romance options and
squad mates are expected to arrive soon
so you'll be able to decide who's going
to be your one true love in the
Andromeda galaxy before too long be sure
to head to gamespot for our gallery on
the 12 things you might have missed in
the new Andromeda trailers and i'll
catch you next time those needs to be
told
I